das oberfränkische langensendelbach hat
den neuen wertstoffhof an den nordrand
gebaut voraussetzung für die
baugenehmigung diese neue
linksabbiegespur so will es das
zuständige landratsamt kosten für die
gemeinde satte 320.000 euro
aber die abbiegespur ist völlig
überflüssig weil aus dieser richtung gar
keine kundschaft kommt denn die
benachbarten ortschaften liegen in einem
anderen landkreis mit eigenem
wertstoffhof also für uns ist es
völliger unsinn
steuerverschwendung buer mir als
ehrlichen bauhof den wieder bei der
nutzen die spur überhaupt nicht und also
völliger quatsch geld zum fenster
rausgeschmissen wie gesagt ist
eigentlich schon ärgerlich wenn man sich
die sachlage anschaut ist es ja klar
dass es unsinnig ist also weil die
anderen aus den anderen gemeinden dürfen
es ja gar nicht verwenden weil die haben
ihren eigenen wertstoffhof weil der alte
bau und wertstoffhof aus allen nähten
platzt setzt die gemeinde einen neuen
auf die grüne wiese mit einer menge
eigenleistung der mitarbeiter des
bauhofs spart die kommune mehr als
300.000 euro ein aber das mühevoll
eingesparte gilt muss dann in den umbau
der straße gesteckt werden
denn das landratsamt forchheim tritt auf
den plan und besteht auf einer eigenen
linksabbiegespur die ist aber völlig
sinnlos der grund die bürger aus den
benachbarten kommunen müssen die
wertstoffhöfe in ihrem landkreis
erlangen höchstadt anfahren im rathaus
von langensendelbach ist der ärger über
die geldverschwendung groß an dieser
stelle hätte man nach unserem
dafürhalten diesen enormen kostenaufwand
nicht gebraucht sondern es wäre
einfacher abi die möglichkeit
ausreichend quiz im landratsamt
forchheim will sich zu dem fall niemand
vor der kamera äußern schriftlich heißt
es es gehe alles streng nach recht und
gesetz
aus gründen der sicherheit und
leichtigkeit des verkehrs war somit
erforderlich die neue zufahrt
entsprechend den geltenden regelwerken
und vorschriften herzustellen
in langensendelbach kann man die
entscheidung des landratsamtes nicht
nachvollziehen
in jedem mit dem man sich unterhält der
sehen was da passiert ist totaler
blödsinn das hat man nicht gebraucht so
viel geld auszugehen auf der spur ist
nichts los da könnte man vier
gemeindefeste tische und stühle
hinstellen
dann werden die 320.000 euro sehr gut
genutzt für die linksabbiegespur die
niemand in langensendelbach braucht muss
die gemeinde jetzt auch noch eine ablöse
von 50.000 euro zahlen damit sie etwa im
winter gestreut wird